Michael Dixon the punter didn't get
named and his Twitter handle was only
six letters long but uh you know you got
to find a space no good when you mess
with punters you mess with me so I said
we've got to call Tom Herman and hold
him to account and that is the way I
welcome in the new coach of Texas
football Tom Herman here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach I'm doing
great rich what a welcome I appreciate
it I'm fired up coach you know what I'm
saying I get fired like that yeah so why
why why'd you slag on your punter like
that I just kind of a fun little veal I
do since I've been a head coach I I
refuse to call specialists but by their
name till they graduate I I just I got a
hard time you know hopefully Michael
only plays about six six plays a game
and you know hopefully you know the dead
six plays a game I'm not sure that the
head coach needs that you deserve to be
called by your first name so when they
graduate I called by their first name
but until then they're the punter of the
kicker and the deep snapper or or from
what I've read other names to coach that
are safer work right but when they screw
up yeah they've been called other names
but whiskey drinkers three with that
whiskey drinkers change smokers is this
good is that true I don't know that I've
ever called them that game but I'd like
to have fun and thing cuz you know I
mean they say they kick for a little bit
in the beginning of practice and you
don't see him until then and you're like
well where did you guys go what are you
doing over there drinking whiskey and
smoking cigarettes okay long no
Hasselbeck Matt Hasselbeck always says
that if you want to know what's going on
in a soap opera or a TV show you ask the
punters in the kicker's because that's
what they're doing during practice
that's know does tell me sneak away into
the equipment room and watch Days of Our
Lives or something like that but you
know but then but I you know I am
I've been I've been holding up four
punters and kickers to coach for years
and I just saw that and I just figured I
had a I just had to kick the tires in
this whole thing and me I know and and I
appreciate you standing up for the
little people in this in this business
but I know when they when they graduate
and they do really good and the good
thing is our funner you know he was a
Rea guy finalist as a sophomore last
year and so we from what I've heard he's
he's a pretty good player and so but
that's still not going to change my my
stance on when I when I officially call
him by his first name well I got it I
got it I guess hey look things have been
working out for you on how you conduct
yourself and your business now head
coach in Texas I do want to talk about
your journey because it's fascinating to
me that you part of your background
comes from the sports television
business where you were a production
assistant and cut and tape for Fox
Sports correct coach yeah and NFL on Fox
actually I was I would drive to the set
on Sundays and I was a I can't remember
my title highlight coordinator or
whatever but I think you know I my job
was to sit and watch a game and log-log
the game and and you know each
screenshot when the when the camera
would would make a different screenshot
I would I would log it you know hey
close up on him and Smith you know you
know whatever the case may be and then
so when when Howie JB and Terry you know
and when you're watching the Packers
versus the Vikings and they say hey
let's let's find out how the Rams and
the Falcons are doing you know the
settle 10 second 15 second highlight
deal which would be my creation and I
thought I wanted to be like you rich to
be honest with you growing up I did PA
announcing for all of our men's women's
basketball and baseball and college and
at my own radio show the whole nine so I
at one point in my life I was really
screwed up and then
I thought I wanted I thought I wanted to
be one of you guys but it didn't work
out that way but I had a really good
time doing it
well you know I remember when I was
doing highlights on SportsCenter way
back in the day perhaps before you were
in with Fox Sports that when I was all I
absolutely remember you on on
SportsCenter you were you were one of my
favorites on
don't sell yourself short o tremendous
stuff great Caddyshack reference love it
but okay so way back when I was a
tremendous lauch on SportsCenter when I
you know I do the shot sheet and I know
that you know I had somebody's very hard
work in my hand that if I did the
highlight improperly or I screwed it up
that their hard work wasn't properly
executed who was that guy on Fox Tom
let's let's call him out like was it
Terry was that the guy who you would
when you handed it off you're like you
were wondering if he was gonna Ollie
done right you know I thought those guys
are pros man they've got really really
good the thing that I was always amazed
just in there was that how big of human
beings Terry Bradshaw and James Brown
are I mean I think if I'm not mistaken I
think James Brown wears a bigger size
coat than Howie long there's no doubt
long you know is an enormous man I mean
he's a big dude and and gabion carrier
began in Terry for being a quarterback
is a big guy too and so no but they I
never really worried about me and off
the shot sheet to any of those guys
they've been doing it for so long and
they're really good at what they do
so when did you a Tom Herman now of
Texas football here on the Richard sir
when did you decide you know what I'm
gonna I'm going to go through the
process of becoming a coach a football
coach when did that how did that
transformation begin uh really the the
summer before my last fall I red shirted
so I spent four and a half years in
college I graduated in December and the
last the summer before my last fall this
kind of oh this ponder in life and
what I was going to do and I just always
I wanted I wanted to do something that
when I woke up before the alarm clock
and where I was fired up every day to do
that and although I had spent my college
years you know kind of in the broadcast
world but no offense it didn't it didn't
dumb impassion me the way that really
being in the locker room and competing
on the field did and I mean I was never
going to play this game professionally
as a player so I I just said hey what's
the you know what's the next best thing
and to me it was coaching and I knew
that I can always do this and it's very
nomadic that doesn't pay very much I
mean my first job was $5,000 a year
coaching Division three football and and
I always knew a 30 if it wasn't for me
or 29 30 31 that's that I could always
hang up the whistle and go do something
else but I knew that if I was sitting in
a cubicle somewhere or doing whatever
selling insurance somewhere that and at
30 31 years old if I wanted to go be a
coach that was probably an impossibility
so I said hey I'm going to try this
while I'm young and see if it's for me
and then it stuck Tom Herman Longhorns
football coach joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and now you are running
the Texas football program with a camp
opening up next week what do you tell
the rabid Longhorn fan base that is
dying for a quick turnaround what do you
tell them coach uh I tell them it's good
to have expectations it's good to want
to win I think that's you know as mack
brown quoting darrell royal you know
this is one of if not the best jobs in
the world because tens of millions of
people care passionately about how well
you do it can be also a very difficult
job because tens of millions of people
care very passionately about about how
you do and so I think it's good to have
expectations but I think it's also smart
to be realistic that you know this we've
got three straight seven loss seasons
and
expect I mean let's look at history I
mean history it isn't full of very many
programs that have gone three straight
seven lost seasons and then boom you win
twelve games or 13 games or you know
you're playing for national champion
Hampstead I I think that if if we can
turn the corner and we can and when you
turn on your TV rich if and when people
are in the stand that they can say
that's one of the hardest plane hardest
hitting most physical teams that that
I've seen then then we'll be on the
right track and the ones will come
eventually if we can accomplish those
goals so if my goal going into this
interview coach to finish up was to
change your mind set on that punters are
people that they're human beings too I
did not accomplish this gold can I leave
you with any sort of change of heart on
the fact that these people are human
beings on the planet who need to be
named the human beings on the planet
outside with need to be named absolutely
not no your own o own one on that drive
a Ridge that um you know when when you
only play six plays a game and you kick
the ball for a living and yeah I know
you change momentum no you change
momentum you change field position I
mean I we play a tremendous amount of
starters on our fun team it's it's
phenomenal uh you know one of our four
plans to win is when the special teams
battle is the hidden yardage and so I I
realized they're important but it's
again just a fun thing that I like to
have and maybe maybe it encourages them
to get their degree as well it is all
about the kids when it all comes down to
it uh no doubt it's just the form of
motivation to get your dreams and I'll
call you Saturday ah oh gosh coach has
been a fun chat getting to meet you I
hope it's the first of many times on
this show and I'll try and change your
your outlook at some hybrid to enjoy
listening to you man host Awards
Thanks you got it thanks for joining us
tom so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen shell app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show